[音楽]
小学校か幼稚園に入る前でしょうか
物心がつき始めた頃私の最大の疑問は自分はなぜ生まれたんだろうというものでした
来る日も来る日も大空あるいは夜空を見上げ
また遠くの山を見るたび
あの空や山の国はどうなっているのだろう
自分はどうして生まれたのだろう
そんなことばっかり考えていました
小学校高学年になって
自分が生まれた謎を解明するには
生命の誕生
地球の形成
太陽系の起源
そして凛がと宇宙の謎を解明しないといけないということが分かりました
中学1年生の時
学校の図書室で読んだ
が毛布前週の宇宙の創造という本には自分の誕生の謎を解きほぐす物語が中学生にも
わかるように書いてあり
いたく感動したのです
この時の感動が宇宙物役者を目指すきっかけとなりました
というわけで
48年前に宇宙物理学者を目指して京都大学の理学部に進学しました
大学に入った頃にわかってきた新たの謎
最大の謎が遠方の銀河の中心の大爆発でした
銀河とは星が1000億も集まっている星の大集団のことです
天の川も銀河の一種ですね
リンガ型とも呼ばれます
遠方の多くの美しい銀河の中心で謎の大爆発が起きており大量の放射線がまき散らされ
ているということがわかってきたのです
まったく不思議ですそして恐ろしい
これだ
銀河の中心の
謎の大爆発を解明しようと思いました
4回生になって太陽観測実習のゼミに参加しました
京都大学には花山天文台と飛騨天文台があり
太陽観測で世界の最先端の研究を進めています
私はてが不器用で機械いじりや実験が苦手です
しかし数学や理論物理は好きでした
そういうこともあって大学院では宇宙物理学の理論研究により
銀河中心の大爆発の謎の解明を目指すつもりでした
でも学部生の時ぐらいは観測の経験もした方が良いだろう
せっかく2つも天文台がある大学に入ったのだから
と思って卒業研究には太陽観測ゼミを選んだのです
ところがゼミに参加して驚きました
毎日見えている対応には謎などは一つもないだろうと思っていたら
黒点ですらまだ発生する仕組みが謎というではありませんか
しかも国楽黒点があるためにしょっちゅうフレアという爆発が起きている
そのフレア爆発の原因もよくわかっていない
というのです
普段チラチラと
対応を眺めているだけでは決して分からない
太陽の謎を知って
にわかに対応に興味を持つようになりました
ゼミで対応のことを詳しく学ぶにつれ
太陽フレアは銀河中心の大爆発に比べて規模はずっと小さいものの物理的がよくにてみ
た性質を示している
ということも分かってきました
銀河中心から放たれる光やべんぱの発生には
磁場が重要な役割を果たしている
いろんな回聖書を読むとそんなことが書いてあります
と思ったんですね
太陽フレアはまだ3回目とはいえ
磁場が原因であるということは分かっている
太陽フレアのメカニズムを解明したら
銀河中心の爆発の謎を解明するのに役立つヒントが得られるかもしれないと思ったの
ですね
はいここで少し詳しく太陽フレアとはどんな現象か説明してをおきましょう
フレアとは対応面で発生する爆発現象のことで対応面爆発とも言います
近年の観測の発展により対応は爆発だらけであるということが判明しました
この画像は陽光と呼ばれる衛星が捉えた太陽頃の x 線の様子です
x 線でピカピカっと光るのはフレアです
このように対応は我々にとって危険な放射線である x 線を大量に放出しているの
ですね
幸い我々は地球の熱い帯域で守られているので
対応のエッグ線に被曝することはありません
しかし宇宙飛行士は大気の外にいるので常に x 線被曝の恐れがあります
プレイヤーは黒点の近傍で発生します
黒点の正体は強い時期です
地磁気の数千倍にも上る強い時期があります
その時期のエネルギーが原因でフレア爆発が起こることが
20世紀の中ごろに確立しました
時期の原因は電流ですから
電流のエネルギーで爆発すると言っても良いですね
太陽黒点の近くで突然電流が激しく流れると
大量のガスが磁気の力を受けて対応の外に猛スピードで飛び出します
私を含む日本の対応物理学の研究チームは
八工衛星の x 線データを詳しく分析することによって
プレイヤーの発生日カンリズムや大量のガスが噴出する仕組みを世界に先駆けて解明
するのに成功したのです
こういうわけでフレアが起こると強いエックス線が放射されるだけでなく
大量の放射性粒子や高速プラズマ流が噴出します
これらが地球に到達すると
人工衛星が故障したり
磁気圏が影響を受けて直原しが起こり
地上で停電や通信障害が起きたりします
直原しが起きると
アラスカや
北欧の夜空には美しいオーラが発生します
この時オーラが光る超高層大気中には
大電流が中でこれが治療の電線に大電流を結城市
変電所の変圧器を壊したり
するんですね
そのために電気が送れなくなって街全体が丁寧になったりするのです
1989年3月に起きた大フレアに伴う次期嵐は
巨大なものでカナダのケベック州全体で大停電を引き起こしました
この時600万人が9時間電気が使えない状態になったといいます
カナダ
アメリカの被害額は少なくとも
見積もっても総額数百億円に達したそうです
史上最大といわれる1859年のフレイヤーが地球を直撃したら
200兆円の被害となるだろうという水産もあります
現代文明が発展すればするほど太陽フレアの影響に対して文明社会は脆弱になりつつ
あります
被害を最小限にするためには
太陽フレアーや時期嵐を
前に予測することが必要です
宇宙飛行士の放射線被曝事故だけは絶対ふさがなければなりません
このような予測のことを
宇宙天気方と呼んでおり現在全世界の緊急の課題となっています
次にスーパーフレアという現象のことをお話しましょう
スーパーフレアーとは
現在対応で観測されている最大級のフレアーの10倍以上のエネルギーを
奉仕する超巨大触れ合うことを言います
そんなスーパープレイヤーが対応で起きる可能性はあるのでしょうか
そもそも対応フレイはどれくらいの頻度で発生しているのでしょうか
調べるとフレアのエネルギーが10倍になると
発生頻度がだいたい10分の1になるということが分かりました
興味深いことにこの法則は地震の発生頻度に関する統計法則と似ています
宇宙飛行士が船外活動している時に
10年に一回の大フレイ起きたら
致死量の放射線を浴びる可能性が
あると言われています
もし太陽フレアの統計がずっと大きなスーパーフレアまで成り立っているならば
最大のフレイヤーの100倍程度のスーパープレイヤーは
数千年に1回の頻度で起きることが予想されます
このようなスーパーフレアが起きたら
宇宙ステーションの中にいても宇宙飛行士は致死量の放射線を浴びるかもしれません
人工衛星がすべて壊れ
地上電力や通信網が破壊されることになるでしょう
これは怖い話ですね
ただし対応は誕生以来46億年も経っていて活動はかなり弱くなっているので
スーパープレイヤーが起こることはないだろうと思われていました
これが天文学会の常識でした
しかし私は
この常識を
疑いました
大学の学生処分の助けを借りて
対応とよく似た8万個の対応がた星の明るさの変化を詳しく
調べました
幸いなことに太陽系外惑星探査が目的のケプラー宇宙望遠鏡によって
観測された8万個の対応型性の公開データがあったのです
対応型生徒は太陽とよく似た性質を持つ
星のことで
あります
このデータを詳しく調べたところ
驚くべきことに148の星出さんビュー365回のスーパーフレアが
見つかったんですね
詳しく調べるとスーパーフレアの発生頻度の統計は対応フレアの統計とよく似ており
最大級の太陽フレアの100倍のスーパーフレアは数千年に1回の頻度で発生すること
が分かりました
さてスーパーフレアが太陽とよく似た捕手で見つかったということは
スーパープレイヤーが対応ででも起きるかもしれないということを意味します
今後対応で数千年に1回のスーパーフレアが起きて地球を直撃したら
未曾有の大災害となることが予想されます
航空機に乗っていると深刻な放射線症がよう超す放射線量を浴びる可能性がありますし
全地球規模の停電や通信障害
it システムの崩壊が起こるかもしれません
この頻度は2011年の東日本大震災の地震の頻度
千年に1回と同程度ですから
遠い未来の話と思って油断してはなりません
我々は太陽や対応型性を詳しく調べることにより
スーパーフレアの仕組みや全長解明し
未来の大災害に備えなければなりません
すでに我々は放射線だらけの危険極まりない
宇宙空間に宇宙飛行士を送り込んでいます
彼らの生命を守り一般市民が安心して宇宙に進出できるようにするためにも
太陽夜行性の研究は不可欠です
対応や宇宙の正体が判明し初めて明らかになった現代社会の危機を広く市民の方々に
伝えたいと思います
もちろんすぐに心配することはありませんが
何も対策しないと
10年後30年後大変なことになります
そしてカークを正しく理解しして対策をきちんと取りさえすれば社会は安全に保つこと
ができるのです
日本はオーラが見えない国なので
フレアーや力嵐による被害が
これまでほとんどありませんでした
そのため
欧米に比べると太陽フレアに対する対策が
まったくを触れています
また
太陽や宇宙に関する基礎教育が
不十分です
太陽や宇宙に関する規則悪を研究している大学研究室も欧米や中国に比べるとずっと
少ない
その結果を正しく理解している学校教員も極めて少ない状態です
また宇宙や対応を直接体験できる教育施設も数少ない状態です
この花山天文台には40年以上昔私が4年生の
時に使用した太陽望遠鏡が
まだ壊れずに残っています
これを使うと太陽フレアーやプロミネンスのスペクトルが観測できまたフレアーから
飛び出したプロミネンスの速度も図れます
運がよいと h r ファンフィルターを用いてプレイヤーをリアルタイムで観測する
こともできます
また月や惑星を直接眼視観測できる
屈折望遠鏡としては日本で3番目に大きな
45センチ屈折望遠鏡も残っています
対応と太陽系を体験する教育施設としては世界最高の場所とさえ言えます
ところが国立大学の運営費削減により
新しい説を作るには花山天文台のような古い施設は閉鎖すべき
という理由で
現在閉鎖の危機にあるのです
このまま閉鎖されてしまっても良いのでしょうか
この閉鎖が現実味を帯びだした頃
世界の古いで問題はどうなっているのだろうかと疑問に思い
いいレスのグリニッジ天文台を訪問しました
そこは世界の自国の原点で知られていますが
20年ほど前に
閉鎖の危機に直面したという噂があったのです
どうなっているのだろうか
と思い数年前に訪問したら
世界中から観光客が集まる
世界遺産の観光地でいっ
化していたのです
古い望遠鏡や建物はきちんと展示用に保存され
観望会も時より開催
また新しいプラネタリウムや博物館もある
ショップやレストランまであるんですね
多くの人々や子どもたちが集まりにぎわっていました
これは素晴らしい
これぞ歴史的価値のある天文台が目指すべき姿では
ないのでしょうか
それ以来花山天文台宇宙科学館構想を真剣に検討するようになりました
花山天文台の面積は
グリニッジ天文台ある面積と
同じ程度ですね
これならプラネタリウムを作れる市科学館もできる
ある時有名な音楽が火山で問題見学に来られ
すっかり気に入ってくださり以来毎年野外コンサートを開いてくださるようになりまし
た
その後野外音楽堂をつくりましょうと提案されたのです
これも素晴らしいアイディアですよね
このように天文学や宇宙科学自然科学だけでなく
音楽やアートまで融合した総合的な文化拠点ができれば
京都ならではの文化拠点になり得ると思うんです
古いけれどもこれらの貴重な歴史的望遠鏡を今後教育普及ように残すことによって
対応太陽系や右朝に親しむ機会を子供たちに残していきたい
それにはあなたの協力が必要です
対応型の魅力そして脅威を
周りの家族あ
友人の皆さんに伝えてください
私たちが解明してきた太陽と宇宙の真の姿
美しくも爆発だらけの危険な正体を次世代の人々に正しく伝えていきたい
それが私の願いです
ありがとうございました